evil West's kinetic combat thrills as
you dismember Vampires by the bucket
load but it's dragged down by level
design that's both formulaic and
repetitive
evil West asks a simple question what if
Cowboys fought vampires it's the kind of
Off the Wall thinking that gets a Daniel
Craig and Harrison Ford movie greenlit
and developer Flying Wild Hogs certainly
gets a lot of mileage off of this
Whimsical concept set in an alternate
version of 1890s America evil West is
the wild west at its wildest a familiar
backdrop of swinging door saloons
rolling Tumbleweed and abandoned gold
mines are interwoven with Nikola Tesla
inspired Electro steampunk technology in
an assemblage of ravenous bloodsuckers
evil West shines in the heat of battle
when that initial question can be
answered but its strengths are often
diminished by the dated design wrapped
around them the story is a fairly by the
Numbers Affair pitting a vampire hunting
organization against the vampiric enemy
Force threatening the continental United
States you're strapped into the
spur-clad boots of Jesse rentier a
typically Gruff protagonist with very
few emotions Beyond difference his
occasionally pragmatic response to the
absurdity occurring around him is
slightly endearing but it's telling that
I had to look up his name before making
this review
The Narrative does periodically Broach
into some interesting themes for
instance one of the Highborn vampires is
concerned by Humanity's ever-expanding
technology and the threat it will pose
his fellow bloodsuckers but these
threats never really go anywhere the
only one that does revolves around a
smarmy and misogynistic government
official yet his comeuppance isn't as
satisfying as it deserves to be
ultimately these one-dimension
characters and cringe-worthy dialogue
replete with strained expletives that
are easy to ignore
ah it may the story is a little more
than a vehicle for its chaotic combat
compelling you from Dusty town to murky
swamp in research of new monstrosities
to extinguish the most surprising thing
about evil West is that it's more of a
brawler than a shooter the behind the
back third person perspective is
reminiscent of the most recent God of
War games the letting you get up close
and personal as you Pummel enemies to a
bloody pulp Jesse is equipped with a
metal Gauntlet that adds extra heft to
each punch while a Charged uppercut can
be utilized to launch smaller enemies
into the air where you can follow up
with the Cannonball strike to send them
careening into a conveniently placed
Spike trap or stack of TNT Jesse's melee
strikes feel suitably weighty and the
gratuitous Gore that coats each arena in
Blood and Crimson viscera really sells
the power fantasy at evil West's core
eventually The Gauntlet is infused with
electricity further expanding upon your
repertoire with a voltaic variety of new
moves you can pull enemies towards you
or you're new to them sending bolts
coursing through their bones and giving
you a short window to lay waste to their
helpless husks with a Flurry of Blows
most of evil West's challenge comes from
the large number of foes it throws at
you at one time so having this kind of
Mobility is key to survival alongside
the typical Dodge move and a kick that
can interrupt certain attacks there's
also an electrical ground pound that
evaporates multiple enemies at once and
a Shockwave attack that stuns multiple
enemies giving you a brief moment of
respite or the opportunity to focus on a
specific Target while the rest are
locked into place
it's not just about the melee fisticuffs
either Jesse is still packing an arsenal
of deadly firearms that gradually
expands throughout the game rather than
constantly swapping between weapons on
the Fly most of the vampire killing
tools are each assigned a button
pressing shoot on its own will fire
Jesse's six shooter revolver while
aiming down sights will automatically
switch to a rifle for dealing with long
range threats another button fires a
quick Blast From A Boomstick shotgun and
there are a few other special weapons
that I won't spoil here there's no ammo
to collect instead everything works on
cooldowns it's a lot to remember but
combat feels both intuitive and fluid
it's the type of game that would benefit
from having a combo meter just to keep
track of how proficient you are at
slaughtering everything in front of you
but sadly doesn't happen
the enemies you come up against are
initially the varied Bunch too from
leaping werewolf-like creatures and
bulbous humanoids that charge at you
before exploding to Bulky Shield bearing
foes with leeches for appendages and
creatures that burrow Underground when
they're not chucking Boulders at you
each one presents a unique challenge but
they also have moments of weakness when
executing powerful attacks indicated by
a glowing Circle and notable chime
oh
[Music]
shooting their weak point with your
rifle deals massive damage and produces
an oftentimes vital Health drop although
the sheer breath of enemies on screen at
any one time does lead to some
frustrations when trying to execute
techniques such as this it can be
difficult to line up a clear shot when
there's so much traffic in the way and
with so much going on there is some
readability issues with knowing when
enemies are attacking from blind spots
despite these issues evil West is at its
best when it's at its most turbulent it
doesn't take long before minibosses are
reintroduced as regular enemies becoming
another part of the supernatural
Furniture you need to utilize everything
at your disposal to survive as you're
pelted from all sides with an
ever-expanding swath of monstrosities
and it's hard not to smile when emerging
from another scrap by the skin of your
teeth unfortunately this feeling begins
to fade by the time the third act rolls
around and The Well of new enemy types
dries up at this point the game resorts
to throwing the same familiar
combinations of creatures at you over
and over again there are only so many
times you can defeat the same group of
shielded opponents before repetition
sets in part of the problem also lies in
evil West's formulaic design combat
generally takes place within boxed in
areas denoted by spike traps and TNT the
dull and predictable layout of these
areas isn't a significant issue since
juggling all of the abilities at your
disposal is more than engaging enough
but it's outside of combat where it
falters the main path connecting the
game's combat Arenas is marked with a
glowing silver chain you can duck under
barely Hidden Side passages to find
money that's used to upgrade weapons but
this constitutes the lightest of
exploration most of the time you're
simply moving from one shiny object to
another or you'll then watch Jesse climb
up a ledge or squeeze through a gap it
occasionally breaks from the norm
putting you in a perilous Minecart ride
or impeding your progress with a
rudimentary block pushing puzzle but
these moments are few and far between
and are incredibly mundane anyway in a
lot of ways evil West feels like a relic
of the past it's kind of a game you
would Envision playing back in say 2010
or perhaps even earlier the Simplicity
could have been somewhat refreshing when
so many modern games are overly bloated
by comparison but it comes across like a
game short on aspiration combat is
robust relishes and Gore and constantly
Delights with its weighty and satisfying
action it stumbles into tedium towards
the end though both as a result of enemy
over saturation and because it's forced
to carry the load but it's the one
aspect that makes evil West worth
playing the rest of the game is
formulaic and mind-numbingly dull
actively diminishing its high points as
you saunter from one combat Arena to
another I didn't always enjoy my time
with evil West but I hope a sequel was
in the pipeline if only to see flying
wild hog and expand and improve on its
promise
[Music]